people apparently occasionally order
wedding dresses from here or even suits
if they want to be really bling but you
have to have a lot of money to have a
wedding dress and it's very heavy so you
get a bit tired before the ceremony is
over I'm here with more platinum than
I've ever seen in my life
and there's a lump of platinum here of
more than 13 kilos worth nearly 400,000
pounds and I can't lift it and we here
at the Johnson Matthey noble metals
processing plant where they turn this
metal they process it to make catalysts
and it's amazing I think platinum is
really exciting first of all because
there is so little of it in the world on
our planet and the reason is always
believed is that platinum forms an alloy
very easily with iron and so much of the
platinum that was in the original planet
Earth when it's formed has gone down
into the iron core in the middle of the
planet so what's left on the surface is
very very little but it is just enough
to supply our needs but as we go forward
we have more cars with more catalytic
converters as we go to the so-called
hydrogen economy where people want to
burn hydrogen in car engines it is
platinum that is going to be the
catalyst and it's quite doubtful whether
we have enough very soon it may almost
be worth collecting the dust from the
roadside and using that as a source to
get the platinum back that we have
spewed out of the exhaust pipes of cars
I want away the ingot just to see that
really is 13 kilos but I'm not wearing
protective shoes
so my Johnson Matthey host is going to
carry it because he's got the right sort
of shoes
so you can see I wasn't exaggerating in
fact I was being slightly modest that
this is more than 13 kilos oats 13 kilos
188 grams and point 8 grams so that's a
bit extra in the cost you can work it
out for yourself how much it's worth
today so this metal is processed to make
rods like this and this rod has just
come off the machine so it's still
slightly warm because processing it
turns mechanical energy into heat and
then this rod is processed to make
thinner wire here and this way you looks
just like ordinary wire but it's really
heavy
I can hardly lift it that's wire is
turned into really thin wire here if I
can find the end of the wire you can see
the wire goes to nearly as thin as my
hair and that in itself is pretty
amazing but it's the next stage that is
extraordinary they use machines for
knitting or weaving these machines to
make something like this and this is the
catalyst this goes inside a column a
tower which is this diameter it's
operating at medium pressure 10 or 20
atmospheres pressure and this is one
sheet of the catalyst and it really
feels rather like plastic cloth except
it's a bit sharper and it has been woven
you can see this sheet goes across the
tower so you imagine a huge Tower with
the ammonia going down and there are
several sheets like this with different
chemical composition so that they
optimize the reaction you get the best
possible conversion but there's you can
imagine this huge Tower and the
catalysts itself
is really not very thick perhaps this
thickness and it is just the speed of
the gas going through that removes the
heat from the reaction and you can see
it's got really quite a nice herringbone
pattern rather nice in my suit you would
make a nice suit except it's a bit
transparent so you'd see yourself
underneath it so what's amazing is that
there isn't very much metal here but
sheets like this can convert thousands
of tons of chemicals so it's a
fantastically efficient catalyst and
it's thanks to catalysts like this that
the fertilizer is made that is
fertilizing the corn and the other wheat
that you eat so the only way that the
earth can support the population that it
does at the moment is thanks to
catalysts like this so you can see it's
starting a milk
over the top so it's on fire and then
we'll just drop it into the fire and you
can see that that sulfur's burning
really intensely now with a really quite
beautiful flame we're in the vault the
bullion vault of the Bank of England and
I'm really excited I've never seen so
much gold in fact I've never seen so
much of any element